Okay,
I'm heading out with my family on a little family Friday day of fun.
Look how cute this set is.
Oh, my god.
With the scallop detail and the matching set.
Um, so I got this on TikTok Shop.
I haven't really dabbled in TikTok shop that much,
but I saw this set,
and I thought it was perfect for spring and summer here in Charleston.
And I was right.
And I got it in the Navy
because I don't have a ton of navy in my closet,
and we like to diversify,
but it comes in tons of colors.
Look how adorable, though.
You could totally wear this, too, as, like,
just a pair of shorts over,
like, a bikini top,
or you could, like,
throw it on over a bathing suit this summer,
but with the little raffia sandals.
Oh, my gosh,
I feel so cute.
And the little scallop detailing. Come on.